你上北方小館的時候
有沒有試過
叫一客牛肉餡餅
再配一碗小米粥
哇哦 美味
那一碗小米不但是
我們台灣原住民的
神聖作物
更能很好的滋補身體
很多粉絲就關心啦
糖友能不能吃小米粥
會不會讓血糖飆高
其實只要吃完以後
OOO
不但以後放心吃小米粥
血糖還能穩穩的
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
今天要和你分享
吃小米抗三高
助眠 補腎 健脾胃
連續吃小米3個月
有效抗三高
你一定要記住這一句話
早餐要喝一碗小米粥
不是因為健康不健康的問題
而是因為這是你一天當中
最便宜的一餐
小米雖然長得很不起眼
但是它卻有
三大超棒的功效
降血糖
降膽固醇
穩定血壓
是抗三高之寶
我先來講降血糖這件事
根據臨床營養學期刊
研究發現 它說
糖友吃了小米
三個月以上
不論是空腹或用餐後
血糖值下降
連糖化血色素也接近正常值
是不是很棒
我常建議糖友們
把小米加入日常飲食
它不含麩質又容易消化
脾胃吸收好
身體自然更有力量
運化營養
就能夠幫助血糖保持穩定下來
來哦
有糖尿病的人都怕吃粥
對不對
小米粥怕不怕
怕
最怕
血糖爆衝
不要怕
免驚啦
當你吃粥或吃小米粥
廣東粥 海鮮粥
要搭配一件事
那就是做運動
做哪些運動
你可以快走 超慢跑
吃粥升糖快
降血糖速度也很快
你做運動就會更容易
讓血糖回穩了
各位小米降膽固醇的功效
有多棒
小米含有較多的膳食纖維
和不飽和脂肪酸
使小米能夠
清血管
能夠預防便秘
能夠降低動脈硬化的風險
讓你心臟更有力
小米裡頭的
鉀和鎂含量很高
這兩種營養素
對血壓很重要
鉀可以把身體
多餘的鹽份帶走
減少鹽份
對血壓的負擔
鎂有什麼功效
能把緊繃的血管 舒緩開來
這樣血壓自然就下降了
睡不好身體沉嗎
1碗小米粥快速入睡
鋤禾日當午
工作真辛苦
當你感到
生活不順心的時候
千萬別慌 不要睡不好
看看你的錢包和存款
哭出來就算了
哭 也不要哭太久
這時候你務必要好好的
喝一碗小米粥
好好睡覺
好好愛你身邊的人
愛會不會消失
我是不知道了
但我知道
沒顧好你的健康
人就會消失了
來 小米粥健脾去濕氣
最滋補的就是小米粥上的
那一層米油
胃不舒服 手術後
或大陸北方媽媽生產後
都會喝一碗小米粥
它滋補你的效果媲美人參
因此又被稱之為
代參湯
代替人參了
你晚上總是睡不好嗎
小米裡頭有色胺酸
它的含量非常豐富
比白米多7倍
每100公克的小米
就有160毫克的色胺酸
白米只有22毫克
你看看差那麼多
色氨酸能夠幫助你
穩定神經
讓你睡得像嬰兒一樣那麼安穩
總是要吃安眠藥
才能睡覺的人
可以改成吃小米粥
效果真的不錯
常喝小米粥
身體會有什麼樣的變化
你會發現
身體的感受很好
堅持喝一年
不只是代謝變好
連氣色睡眠精神
都大大的升級
最近我有個病人
他跟我說
因為看我以前的節目
他就吃小米粥
結果把他的胃
都給弄好了
所以他前些日子
還送了我一包
特別的小米
他說全台灣只有
一兩個地方可以買得到
天熱天冷
小米加它最對味
不要嫌棄一直陪你的人
不要陪一直嫌棄你的人
小米3種吃法
陪你春夏到秋冬
天熱消暑法和
天冷暖身法
嘿 真好
春夏氣溫高熱
小米加綠豆煮成
煮成綠豆小米粥
綠豆清熱解毒
小米健脾養胃
還可以利尿
就可以把熱給去掉了
喝下一口
彷彿一陣涼風吹過
暑氣都散了
嗯 超消暑
秋冬溫度下降
手腳也跟著冰冷
腰也痠了 背也痛了
那些有的沒的
小毛病都跑出來了
這時候吃上一碗暖暖的
山藥瘦肉小米粥
本草綱目說小米是
腎之穀
小米補腎 補脾胃
山藥補肺益腎
它們搭在一起
脾胃 肺 腎
統統給你補到了
都補好補滿了
讓身體更有力
氣色更好
是不是超棒
腎虛的人會腰痠
手腳冰冷 頻尿
腎熱的人會尿黃
有心煩失眠的
那些個症候
來吃山藥瘦肉小米粥
一口喝下去 溫補腎氣
不只是手腳溫暖了
心也暖了
讓你元氣滿滿
整天都有力氣
愛吃甜甜的人一定要試試
南瓜小米粥
胃不舒服的人
吃了特別好
南瓜的果膠
能夠保護胃壁
胃腸的黏膜
減少潰瘍
消化更順暢
有一句話
人家在吃包子
你在那裡喊燙
建議你喝粥的
趁熱快吃
古人有這麼一句話他說
寧人等粥 毋粥等人
什麼意思呢 說
寧願人來等粥煮好了來吃
也不要讓粥涼了才吃
為什麼呢
因為一碗熱熱溫熱溫熱的粥
入口是最溫補的狀態
同時能養脾胃
小米粥選這種最好吃
加1物不澀苦
小米粥怎麼煮才好吃呢
跟你偷偷的說
我美麗的太太都是用
糯小米煮小米粥
煮出來的口感是
QQ黏滑 黏性更好
每一粒米在嘴裡頭
都慢慢的化開
哇 很讚哦
我們常見的兩種小米
糯小米 梗小米
台灣的原生小米
大多數是糯小米
而從國外進口的呢
常常見到的是梗小米
我們先講糯小米的特色
它好煮又軟黏
煮成粥濃稠滑順
我們台灣的原住民
都用糯小米來煮飯 熬粥
甚至於釀成小米酒
對體力差 容易疲倦的人
或手術大病之後的人呢
吃糯小米補氣益氣
而且幫助你潤腸通便
第二種是梗小米
口感比較硬
煮久了不容易爛
吃起來比較清爽
血糖容易忽高忽低
體質偏濕重
或是有水腫的人
適合吃梗小米
梗小米能夠
健脾除濕清熱安神
而且能夠穩定血糖
有粉絲問我
小米粥怎麼煮
才不會苦苦澀澀的
嘿 跟你說一個bonus
你把小米和白米一起煮成粥
吃起來就不會苦苦的啦
中國的北方人
他們煮粥
常常會在小米粥裡頭
加一點點燕麥片
變成小米燕麥粥
這樣煮的粥啊
口感更滑順
而且延緩升糖速度
對阿公阿嬤們很好
糖友們也能夠
安心的吃了
吃小米也是有眉角哦
要注意的
這兩種人不能多吃小米
第一種小便量比較多的人
第二種體質虛寒的人
因為小米它有利尿的作用
你是小便量比較多的人
可以吃小米粥
但不要吃太多碗
也不要在睡前吃太多
否則本來想用
喝小米粥來助眠的
結果卻一直上廁所
一直上廁所
就達不到
你要的養生效果了
建議適量喝就好
第二種是
體質虛寒的人
也不建議
你吃太多小米
虛寒體質的人啊 冬天容易
手腳冰冷 怕冷
大便偏稀
多吃小米粥
會讓身體更寒
反而不舒服
所以這類人吃小米粥
可以搭配溫熱的食材
或少量的吃
才能真正的養脾暖胃
小米從窮人的糧食
變成國際巨星
原住民的朋友
你們最愛喝小米酒
對不對
你們真的很有智慧
把小米釀成小米酒
你知道嗎
在四五千年前
中國北方新石器時代的遺址
就有小米釀酒的這種證據哦
從夏朝 商朝開始
小米就是北方人的主糧
中國以前把小米稱之為粟
粟文化從古流傳到宋遼金
甚至現在在大陸的北方
媽媽生產完小孩
媽媽生產完
甚至現在在大陸北方
媽媽生產完之後
還會喝小米粥來補身
你以為中國是小米的生產王國
哼 不是啦
印度才是
全球最大的小米生產國
不只會煮粥
人家還做大餅 薄餅
搭扁豆煮出美味來
聽說啊甚至在2018年
印度政府宣布將當年定為
國內小米年
並向聯合國提議
把2023年定為
國際小米年
最終獲得通過
哈哈
小米真是太棒了啊
親愛的粉絲們
我們已經開啟會員頻道了
如果你認同胡醫師推廣中醫
照顧自己健康的理念
歡迎每月小額支持
或成為VIP贊助者
有你同行
我們才能走得更遠
真心感謝你哦